we are going to be looking at a couple
of opening traps okay from a long long
long time ago yes yes do you already
know the girls made all right well you
can you can sit silently during the
Legaspi time till we uh go through it
and then we'll decide right now the
girls word everybody know what it like
Gollum eight is no we're gonna go over
this that's why I'm asking if everybody
knows it
okay all right since you know you're not
going to tell anybody but we're gonna go
through some opening traps and first
we're going to try to figure out some
opening moves what's good what's bad
what's wrong what's right and normally
we're going to go on the same topic what
are the things that you want to do in
the opening yes control the center
develop your pieces what else you yes
you want to make your King safe right
usually you do this by castling not
always but most of the time you want to
make sure your king is safe you want to
make sure that you castle you want to
make sure that nothing is going to
attack your king so you make your peace
your king safe you develop your pieces
and you control the center yes everybody
agree with this most openings are all
about this now do you want to develop
some of the pieces of all of your pieces
all of your pieces all right there's no
piece that should be left behind unless
there's something very immediate okay so
we're going to first be looking at one
of the most classical classical examples
of an opening trap in chess so here
we're going to start with the moves
efore e5 Knight f3 d6 and we looked at
this last closer last week I know there
were some people here last week who was
here last week just raise your hand
who was here last week for this lesson
all right so we had a couple people so
we did some opening review last week
right we went some openings we learned
the names of them and we were trying to
figure out if they're good or not
so what is this opening called from last
week yes yes why is it called the
Philidor ooh anybody know why anybody
know who filter was know what it's not a
what it's a who-who Philidor was one of
the first great thinkers of chess he
lived a long long time ago he was back
he lived back in the 1700s so that was
quite a while ago and he came up with
the idea that in chess the most
important pieces were the pawns the
pawns were the soul of the chessboard
but anyways d6 is known as the Philidor
and here white played Bishop c4 this is
a decent move is it good everybody liked
it everybody not like it all right what
about Bishop g4 there's a develop a
piece yeah
is it control the center and not exactly
right it indirectly controls the center
because the knight has some influence on
the center squares right however if the
bishop removes the knight then there's
less pressure in the center right now
normally when you're beginning as a
chess player I normally recommend you
develop Knights before you develop
bishops and the reason is that it's
usually more obvious where the Knights
go then where the bishops go for
examples maybe this Bishop wants to go
here and trade itself for this one
maybe the bishop wants to go here maybe
the Misha cannot move and will move
later but
most of the time the Knights go to
either c6 or f6 so usually you want to
move out your Knights before your
bishops by Bishop g4 it's not a bad move
like I'll play Knight c3 which is this a
good move looks okay right right and now
black play the kind of weird move g6 now
what can you tell me about the move g6
he's opening up this bishop right but
the bishop already have a diagonal to go
to right it did right where could the
bishop go yes
yeah I can go to e7 so you can develop
immediately with something along the
lines of Bishop e7 or you can maybe
develop even stronger Knight to c6
but g6 moves another pawn and normally
when you move too many pawns in the
opening you're not developing your
pieces and we are not developing your
pieces bad things can happen so
something bad happened here for black
after g6 what black yes I know you know
so after a g6 Y takes on e5 now when
we're looking at this in the previous
lesson right the idea is that after
Knight takes e5 if pawn takes e5 Queen
takes g4 how much material is white up
one pawn right so
black took on d1 and this was also a
problem for black yes I know you know
also people that were in the last class
are not allowed to answer this one
so here black run into a problem even
though that he won a queen his
development is so bad and his King is so
unsafe that he ended up losing the idea
is that after Bishop takes f7 King e 795
he got checkmated so it's not such a
good idea to move too many pawns in the
opening and you can run into some
problems when you don't develop your
pieces all right so we're going to take
a look at some other traps that
hopefully you guys don't know we looked
at this one no not this one okay ah now
in chess it's important that your king
is safe and I cannot stress this out
enough we're going to take a look at a
pretty complicated and really old game
that exemplifies that even though there
is no immediate checkmate the most
important thing is to have a safe King
yes No thank God
no all right after efore there's no way
you know every chop I'm going to teach
you today
efore e5 Knight f3 knight c6 white play
the surprising move c3 now this move
violates one of the concepts in shots
that we talked about which one
sorry yeah you're playing too many pawn
moves what is it not doing well
yes developing your thesis you go ahead
yes you're not developing your pieces
right so this is not considered to be a
main line opening but it's blind once in
a while does anybody know the name of
this opening yes nepal's eonni very good
did I write that yeah the pons eonni
alright so after c3 what is White's idea
why do you think he played the move c3
anybody that's not you yes yeah he wants
to play the move d4 so that when black
captures on d4 I can capture with my
pawn and have a strong pawn Center and
even though this is a very nice idea it
has the problem that black also gets to
play his own moves so nowadays we know
that d5 is the strongest move to the
pawns eonni the idea is that if you take
on d5 Queen takes d5 usually bringing
your queen out to the centres about idea
but in this case because there's already
a pawn on c3 this Knight cannot develop
and attack the Queen
alright instead of that black in this
position play Knight f6 and so now we're
going to get into kind of a complicated
game d4 was played
now if pawn takes d4 does white
absolutely have to take on d4 no what
can he do instead yeah
yeah we're going to call them Knights
although they look like horses their
horse is actually in some languages and
Spanish their horses not sure what other
language is their horses in but in
English your Knights what else can we
play so you could play 90 xp for what
else yes
so let's attack something with something
that's worth less yes yeah the movie is
e5 so the idea of ePHI is that now the
night is not hanging to the night
so the pawn is not hanging to the night
and this night is under attack on f6
right everybody agree with this yes so
if the knight moves away
I can now recapture the pawn and this
pawn on e4 is no longer under attack if
I played etext e4 c text e4 immediately
then he can take my pawn everybody agree
with this all right so after Knight
takes e4 immediately what options does
white have
what looks like logical chess moves here
yeah somebody yes yes Bishop d3 looks
alright it attacks the knight looks
pretty logical yeah absolutely pawn
takes e5 well that's not necessary you
can just take only five yeah so the
pawns defend that you cannot take only
five yeah yeah and that's actually what
happened in the game also a very strong
move the idea is that black loses the
defense of the e5 pawn because this pawn
is kicking away the night so after
ninety seven ninety five both sides have
more or less played logical moves black
decided to play Knight g6 which was
probably not the best he maybe should
have played d6 kicking out this Knight
and allowing his pieces to develop so
after ninety six white actually ignored
his knight on e5 he could take and be
okay yes he could play Queen e2 it's
also a decent move after Knight takes
Queen takes Queen e7 the position is
probably about equal he played instead
the move Bishop d3 which is also
possible now black should take this
knight on e5 and why should take this
bit knight on e4 and then we still have
equal material and now black tried to be
very clever he played the move Knight
takes f2 so after Knight takes f2 what
is black threatening the Queen yes now
why do you think he gave up a knight yes
well Queen f6 check attacks the King and
attacks the knight but now I can defend
both with 9 f3 right so that doesn't
quite work what do you think blacks idea
was it's a little simpler than that ok
you could go Queen h4 but I guess I can
defend with g3 that still doesn't seem
too convincing to me yes yes just Knight
takes e5 so the idea is that after
Knight takes f2 King takes f2 9 takes e5
who ended up with more material how much
one pawn right so here they're equal but
because black played this kind of clever
move Knight takes f2 then after King
takes f29 takes e5 blacks up a pawn yes
in the back and white can't castle
anymore which is kind of an issue this
King he is not so happy actually yeah
it's not very happy yeah
you could actually Castle artificially
and for the King on g1 but okay we're
strafing from the lesson but the point
is your blocks up upon right so why
doesn't want to do this
so after nine takes F 2 white played the
move Bishop takes g6 now does that look
like a good move or a bad move
okay well do not get a consensus on that
so Bishop takes g6 what happens if he
just takes my bishop then you just take
the knight now we know that I'm Queen f6
I can defend right so now who has more
material yeah
well we'll look at that don't get ahead
of it we're looking first at pawn takes
Bishop will look at Knight takes Queen
later
so pawn takes Bishop King takes f2 and
now who has more material white how much
what more versus right one Knights worth
3 1 points worth 1 why it's obviously
your head right everybody agree with
that
any questions about that no my questions
okay so instead of that black took on d1
now how much material is black up a he's
up a lot not quite 9 because I think I
have an extra night for the Queen but
black didn't see why it's very clever
threat yes g7
right and that was the point of blacks
whites idea now after the move
what's blacks forced move go forward
we're right over always the letter first
this X right correct so the king has to
go to d6 and now what's the best move
for white origin yeah sure you could
take the Queen now I'm going to teach
you something that a famous world
champion was said does anybody know the
world champions first of all is anybody
know what a world champion is yes a
world champion is who wins a tournament
or a match and everybody considers him
to be the best chess player in the world
all right who's the world champion right
now yes Magnus Carlsen is the reigning
world chess champion that's right
he's from Norway now back in the year
1900 exactly 1900 who was the world
champion yes I'll take the guess but
Kasparov I think I think I think his
parents hadn't been born yet no there
was this guy called Emmanuel Lasker and
Lasker said something very important for
chess players when you see a good move
think and find a better one what he was
saying is that just because you find a
good move doesn't mean you need to play
it there might be a better alternative
somewhere hidden and this applies to
chess this applies to life this applies
to a lot of things if you see something
that you want to do first think about it
see if there's better options and maybe
you'll come up with a better idea
in this case Bishop takes Queen is not a
bad move but there's a much stronger one
Knight c4 check keying c5 is forced
right everybody agree with this king c5
and now instead of taking the Queen
which still okay white play the move
Knight b2 a3
what happens if Queen takes g5 yes
b4 would be checkmate right well yeah
yeah I agreed right I mean the King
cannot go here because of this night
whoops that night doesn't move like that
because this night the special defense
this pawn this Knight defense this guy's
this Knight defense this this pawn
defense this and this pawn defense this
that looks like a pretty picture on this
defenses so everybody agree with that
okay so this should be checkmate yeah I
agree with that
all right okay so instead of that why
black has to do something like defend
against before but it's not so easy what
can you suggest yeah you could play the
move a5 but now I take your queen
and now you're doing really well instead
after a five I can take on the Queen on
d8 and now the game is pretty much over
right okay let's take another look at
another one this one so we're going to
take a look at this position what is
this known as yes the Italian game right
and what are some logical moves for
block here yes yes Bishop c5 is probably
the most common move among grandmasters
what else anybody that's not you logical
moves here just logical ideas remember
develop Center all this kind of stuff
yes
f6 would be okay does go towards the
center but it doesn't develop a me is it
a night yeah so the knight can go to
have sex what you're saying yeah that's
the second most common move among
grandmasters by far
definitely Knight f6 and Bishop c5 are
the most common moves other moves are
okay there's Bishop e7 it's okay
d6 is okay as long as you're developing
I think I'm going to be happy however
black plays this move Knight d4 now what
moves what rules
if justices violate yes now move the
same piece twice because you want to
develop all of your pieces right now
what else it's not developing now but
what else is the knight doing or not
doing what did it stop doing well what
job did the knight have on c6 think of
jobs for different
think of jobs yes it was protecting the
Queen from who who so well 94 let's go
back
the idea of night f3 is what yes it
attacks the 5 point so the idea of 96 is
that it defends the phone right so when
I play Bishop c4 and you go Knight d4
what are you not doing you're not
protecting the pawn all right so should
I take it why not why yes yes sure sorry
Queen d7 will be not too bad it does
cure the knight to the pawn but there's
even a stronger movement this is an old
trap so what I'm trying to warn you guys
is that even if your opponents make bad
moves it doesn't mean that you need to
punish them immediately you should
always do what you're supposed to be
doing you're supposed to Castle you're
supposed to develop your pieces so for
example a perfectly good move in this
position is to ignore everything in
castle you put your King safe you
develop your pieces you're doing what
you're supposed to do and that gives you
a much higher chance of winning than if
you try to punish and go for pawns or
start taking pieces develop your pieces
go towards the center just the basics
instead of that why it was very greedy
and he played 9 takes e5 so here what
black played the move Queen g5 which is
what we know in chess is a double attack
the Queen attacks ePHI and it attacks g2
right now you cannot defend both of them
so white went on on his own
counter-attack and played Knight takes
f7 now you're attacking the Queen and
you're attacking the rook right
now the bishop is defending this night
so you cannot take that and black plate
Queen takes g2 attacking the rook so
white thought hey this Knight is
attacking the rook that's trapped I'm
going to move my rook and put it in
safety
can anybody defend this rook who how
right you can move the rook over to f1
and that's what happened in the game but
then after Queen takes e4 Chuck black
white wasn't a little bit of an awkward
position it's not checkmate can I block
with the Queen
do I want to block with the Queen now
right because then I lose my Queen to
the knight
so what do I want to block with use the
bishop
but unfortunately for white this was
also quite a bad idea because after
Knight f3 check that's checkmate right
because this rook blocks out the King
this one cannot go anywhere the bishop
cannot take because there's a pin and
that's checkmate so what did we learn
today what are we doing in the opening
are we grabbing pawns yes sure
well White's checkmated here but I mean
from the beginning you should develop
your pieces you need to put your king in
safety you need to control the center ok
that's it don't go around pawn grabbing
okay
don't lose your pieces develop them
control the center castle
you